>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
I have to tell you.
I have had a lot of fun standing
back there for the last couple
of minutes and listening to
your questions and your energy.
Because I have a feeling the next
hour is going to be a lot of fun.
So my name is Lee Ann Potter.
And I work here at the
Library of Congress.
And I get to officially
welcome you to the Library
of Congress this morning.
So officially, welcome!
>> Thank you.
>> Lee Ann Potter: [Laughter]
And I also have an opportunity
to welcome an audience that is
elsewhere around the country
and around the world because we
are live streaming this event
so that the questions you
ask are probably questions
that other children have in mind and
you're kind of speaking on behalf
of all those other kids today.
So I know your questions
are going to be great.
And in addition to welcoming
you to the Library of Congress,
I get to welcome you to the Young
Readers Center here at the Library.
If you have been to the Library
of Congress before, can
you raise your hand?
Okay, about maybe a third of you?
Those of you who've
been here before,
have you been to this room before?
>> Yeah, I have.
>> Lee Ann Potter: All right.
Well, those of you who
haven't been, this room is sort
of like the children's
room in your local library.
What sorts of things -- psst --
what sorts of things are in
your library at your school?
>> Books [inaudible].
>> Lee Ann Potter: What else?
>> Shelves?
>> Lee Ann Potter: Say that again.
>> Shelves.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Shelves and
books and what's on the walls?
>> What's on the walls is --
>> More books?
>> Lee Ann Potter:
I like that answer.
You said more books.
But sometimes, there's pictures
and sometimes, there's posters
and all kinds of fun
things on the walls.
You had something to say.
>> There -- [laughter] it's on the
wall, there is pictures of people.
>> Lee Ann Potter: That's right.
>> And their culture.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Excellent!
Yes, sometimes there's pictures
of people and sometimes,
those people are authors
and sometimes,
those people are famous people and
sometimes those people are you guys.
And I bet some of your artwork
is on the walls in your library.
But here in the Young Readers
Center, we have lots of books
and we have posters on the walls.
And we have opportunities to
do all kinds of activities
with young people like today,
when we have a very
special author with us.
Now, I know you guys all
know what authors are, right?
>> Yes.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
What do authors do?
>> Write books.
>> They write the books.
>> Lee Ann Potter: That's
right, they write the books.
Does the author also
illustrate the books?
>> Yeah.
>> No.
>> Sometimes.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Excellent answer.
That's right, sometimes.
Well, in this case -- you know,
I have a feeling all
of you are authors too.
Have you guys all written stuff?
>> Yeah, to my [inaudible].
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah,
I bet you guys are.
>> Oh, we had to take [inaudible].
>> Lee Ann Potter: Well,
when you guys read books
or when somebody reads you a
book, how often do you think
about the person who wrote the book?
You see, that's my
wish for you today.
I hope that after this
opportunity to meet an author today,
I hope that every single
book you read from now on,
you think a little
bit about the author
and the illustrator of the book.
Because when you read a book and
you make a connection to that book,
you're making a connection
to that author too.
And that's really special.
And you're also making a connection
nobody's ever read the book
or ever will read the book.
And that's really special too.
So I am delighted to be
welcoming Shana Corey here
to the Library of Congress.
She is going to be talking to us
today about a very special book
that she wrote recently
about John F. Kennedy
and a very important speech
that he delivered in 1963.
Now, John F. Kennedy, if he had
been, if he were still alive,
would be celebrating his
100th birthday this month.
Do you guys think 100
is a long time?
>> Today's his birthday?
>> Lee Ann Potter: No,
this month is his birthday.
His birthday would have been
at the end of the month.
Now you are just itching
to say something.
I'm going to call on you and then
I'm going to ask you really nicely
to put your hands down so we
can really get started, okay?
Now what was it that
you wanted to say?
>> Sometimes, I know, sometimes
people paint the walls.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Yes, that's right.
In libraries, sometimes
people paint the walls.
That's so true.
You guys are all going to have
a chance to say things later.
So I'm going to ask you
please put your hands down.
Let's give a very warm welcome to
Shana and welcome you and thank you.
And we're so excited to hear from
you and also hear about the artwork
that is also here that your
colleague contributed to the book.
So thank you.
>> Shana Corey: Thank you.
I am so excited to
be here, you guys.
This is the Library of Congress.
This is like Mission
Control for libraries.
That's pretty cool, right?
>> Yeah!
>> Shana Corey: Yeah.
>> And it's [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: So I'm here
today because I'm an author.
But I wasn't always an author.
Do you guys want to see a picture
of me before I was an author?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, this is me.
You'll like this is me back --
this is me when I was about
your age, maybe first grade.
Does that look like me?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Does it?
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: So would it look
like me if I had a big red hair bow?
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: No?
Well, let's see it.
Do you know who I think
I was really drawing?
I don't think I was
really drawing myself.
You know who I think I was really
drawing when I was drawing this?
Who was that?
>> [Inaudible] Madeleine.
>> Shana Corey: Madeleine.
I love Madeleine.
So Madeleine is this great book.
I bet there's copies
in the back here.
So if you take one pro tip from
today, if you want to learn
to draw a big hair
bow, two triangles
and boom, you have your hair bow.
So that's your first
takeaway from today.
Do you want to see
what I really look
like though when I was your age?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, this is me
when I was in elementary school.
>> Which one are you?
>> Shana Corey: Which one am I?
Okay, raise your hand if you
think I'm the sweet, happy,
nice little girl with braids.
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: No?
Raise your hand if you
think I'm the kind of bossy,
cranky looking big sister.
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: What, you guys?
Okay, you're right.
I'm the [inaudible]
-- okay, hands down.
I'm the bossy big sister.
That's me.
That's me and my sister, Marcie.
Now, I wasn't an author
yet in that picture.
Can you guys hear me?
I wasn't an author
yet in that picture
but I was already doing something
that was getting me
ready to be an author.
What do you think I was
doing when I was in first,
second grade that was getting
me ready to be an author?
What do you think?
>> Reading books.
>> Shana Corey: Oh my gosh,
you guys are such smart kids.
You, look, people don't get that
right away but yes, I was reading.
I loved to read.
Raise your hand if you love to read.
>> Oh, yes.
>> Shana Corey: Oh, good!
Well then, you guys, you're all
on your way to being authors
because reading is the most
important thing you can do
if you want to be an author.
So when I was growing up, these
were some of my favorite books --
Little House on the Prairie ,
Betsy-Tacy , All-of-a-Kind
Family .
In fact, I liked reading so
much that when I grew up,
I decided I wanted to have
a job where I could be
around books all day long.
Can you guys think of any --
what kind of jobs could you
be around books all day long?
>> Author.
>> At the library?
>> Shana Corey: You could
work in the library.
You could be a librarian and then
could you imagine this would be
your office.
And I bet you could take
home any books you wanted.
That would be pretty cool, right?
No? Well --
>> If you worked for
the other [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: You work
for the other people?
What kind of book jobs
can you think of?
>> You can be an author
or an illustrator.
>> Shana Corey: You could
be an author, an illustrator
so you could write or draw
books or draw the pictures.
What kind of book jobs
can you think of?
>> I think you could
be, you could be
around books by painting pictures?
>> Shana Corey: You could paint
pictures like the illustrator
of this book, R. Gregory Picture.
R. Gregory Picture --
R. Gregory Christie.
He painted these pictures
so he's around books all day
and then he draws the pictures.
That's pretty cool.
We'll do one last book job.
What kind of book job
can you think of?
>> One last book job that I can
think of is organizing books.
>> Shana Corey: Oh, that's a
really good one, organizing books.
You think, do you think
librarians organize books?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah, that's
a really smart thought.
>> I do [inaudible] offer
because of your earrings.
>> Shana Corey: I'm
wearing book earrings.
It's true.
So I decided to get a job.
Hold on to your thoughts because
we'll do lots more in a little bit.
I decided to get a job being
something called an editor.
Does anyone know?
What's an editor?
>> An editor likes to make
books like popular books
so that there are more
copies for everyone to read.
>> Shana Corey: Oh, interesting.
So yes, that's part of
what an editor does.
They make sure lots of people are
going to get copies of the books.
What else do you think
an editor does?
And I'm sorry, I didn't -- I
should have repeated your answer
so people -- your friends
far away could hear.
He said that an editor makes
copies of books so lots
of people could read them.
And what else does an editor do?
>> I think an editor
-- I don't know.
>> Shana Corey: So I think an
editor's a lot like a teacher.
Do your teachers help you
make your work better?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, she edit it.
>> Shana Corey: So an
editor works with authors
to help them make their
stories better.
So I got a job as an editor.
Here is my office in New York City.
I work at Random House
Children's Books.
And it's just like I always wanted.
I'm surrounded by books
all day long.
So you guys might recognize
some of these books.
I work on books for big kids.
I work on early readers and a lot
of the early readers I work on are
about history because
I love history.
I see someone pointing.
Do you know that book, George
Washington and the General's Dog ?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> It's at our classroom.
>> He has it.
>> Shana Corey: I love that book.
That's an excellent book.
>> I haven't read it.
>> Shana Corey: So those
-- it's really good.
I really recommend it.
Those books are true stories.
Who can tell me, what's it called
when a book's a true story?
Does anyone know what's a book --
what's it called when
a book's a true story?
>> They -- they also [inaudible]
when they read the book
to children who don't have books.
>> Shana Corey: Oh,
people read books
to children who don't have books?
What were you going to say?
>> What was the question again?
>> Shana Corey: What is it
called, what's it called
when a book is a true story?
>> Fiction.
>> Shana Corey: Whoa, really close.
Nonfiction.
>> Nonfiction.
>> Shana Corey: Yes, exactly.
Nonfiction.
>> [Inaudible] it's something
that's not, it's real.
>> Shana Corey: In fiction,
it's something that's made up.
Exactly. Okay, so I
also work on books.
I've worked on series like
Babymouse and another series
that you guys wouldn't know.
I don't think.
No one's ever heard of
Junie B. Jones, have they?
>> I know!
>> Shana Corey: You
know Junie B. Jones?
Oh, I love Junie.
You have it?
I have it in my backpack too.
I love Junie B. Jones!
So you guys, after -- after I
had been editing for a while,
I decided I wanted to
write my own stories.
Now when you guys write stories,
where do you get your ideas?
Where do you get -- where
do you get your ideas?
>> From your brain.
>> Shana Corey: Sometimes you
just get ideas from your brain.
Where do you get your ideas?
Let's see, where do you,
where do you get your ideas?
>> I sometimes get ideas from books.
>> Shana Corey: From other books,
that's a great place to get ideas.
Where do you get your idea?
>> From -- so sometimes, I get ideas
from maybe my journal
writing or poetry?
>> Shana Corey: That's fabulous.
Yeah, from journal
writing or poetry.
That's a great place to get ideas.
Where do you get your idea?
>> I get my ideas from other
books because when I read a book,
it makes me think of
what I could do.
>> Shana Corey: That's -- listen,
you guys have such great ideas.
So she gets her ideas from her
journals and poetry and other books
because when she reads
books, it gives her ideas
of other things she could do.
Where do you get your ideas?
>> Pictures.
>> Shana Corey: From pictures.
Looking at pictures is a
great place to get ideas.
Okay, we'll do one more.
Is there anyone that hasn't?
We'll do you.
>> So I want to [inaudible]
pictures and facts.
>> Shana Corey: Pictures and facts.
That's a -- are you kids
sure you're first graders?
Those are really good
answers and thoughts.
Yeah, facts and I get a
lot of ideas from facts
because I write a lot of nonfiction.
So I'll tell you about -- come here.
You write nonfiction too?
That's -- I love nonfiction.
So let's put hands down for a
second and I'll tell you about some
of the stories I've written and
then we'll read the one about JFK.
So a lot of my stories, a lot of
my stories -- can you hear me, hon?
A lot of my stories
are about real people,
about people that inspire me.
And I get inspired by people who do
things to create change like things
that are going to [inaudible],
they want to change the world.
So some of my first books
are about real ladies
that lived a long time ago
and they didn't like the kind
of clothes women wore
a long time ago.
>> What kind?
>> Shana Corey: What
kind of clothes?
What -- does anyone know
anything about olden day clothes?
What kind of clothes did
ladies wear a long time ago?
>> I know, they was wearing dresses
that would show your body part.
>> Shana Corey: They were
wearing dresses, long dresses.
Any other, what else do you
know about olden day clothes?
>> And sometimes, they
would only wear hats
because they're only
allowed to wear a hat.
>> Shana Corey: They had to wear
hats and bonnets a lot of times.
In fact, are any of you guys
going to go swimming this summer?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah or?
>> I'm going to go swimming.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah,
are any of you going
to wear a bathing suit
that looks like this?
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: No?
Well, a long time ago, women used
to wear bathing suits
that looked like this.
>> I don't like dresses.
>> Shana Corey: But girls, you're
going to wear tights, right?
You can't go swimming
without tights, right?
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: No?
Well, Annette Kellermann, the
woman on the right, was a real lady
that lived a long time ago.
And she was a champion swimmer.
And she thought, we can't, you can't
win races and set swimming records
in those kind of bathing suits.
So she invented her
own bathing suit.
So I write about a lot
of people like that.
>> That's a bathing
suit [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: That's how
bathing suits were invented.
I also write, I write some books
that are historical fiction.
Does anyone know what's
historical fiction?
Any guesses?
>> Historical fake.
>> Shana Corey: It's
called a fake, yeah.
That's exactly right.
Historical but fake.
So some parts are true.
There's some facts
and some are made up.
So I'm going to tell you which parts
of this are true and
which are made up.
Players in Pigtails is
about a real baseball
league a long time ago,
the All-American Girls
Professional Baseball League.
It was the first girls'
baseball league
and it started during World War II.
All of this is true
because all of the boys
that played baseball went
off to fight in the war.
And President Roosevelt wrote
a letter to the Commissioner
of Baseball -- Roosevelt
and he said,
"You have to keep baseball going."
So they started a girls' league.
So I did all this research
for this book.
Here's real pictures of the team.
Here's another real picture.
But I had a problem.
Hold on to your thought.
I didn't know who to write about
because I had all the facts
about the league but I didn't have
a main character because there were
so many people that played
baseball in this league.
Hold on to your thought.
But then I went to library
because you can always find facts
and answers at the library, right?
Right, so I found this old book
in this secret room that's a room
on the third floor of
the library by my house.
I don't know even know if I
was supposed to be up there.
It was this dusty old
book and I pulled it
out and I blew out the dust.
And when I read it,
I got goose bumps
because this old book had the song.
Does anyone ever know the song,
"Take Me Out to the Ball Game"?
>> Yes!
>> Shana Corey: Can you guys --
we'll all together say just
the first line of the song,
"Take Me Out to the
Ball Game" all together?
>> Take me out to the ball game.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, hold
on to your hats, folks.
Guess what?
That's not really the
first line of that song.
When I opened that book,
I could not believe it.
There's a whole verse
that comes before that.
And that's the kind
of stuff you can find
when you're researching
in libraries.
The real first line of that song
is "Katie Casey is baseball mad,
have the fever and had it bad."
And when I read that,
I got goose bumps.
>> Why?
>> Shana Corey: Because that means
that song that everyone sings
and knows and thinks of
when they think of baseball,
that song is really about a girl.
That's pretty cool, right girls?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: I think
that's really cool.
So I just -- so I decided to make
Katie Casey my name character.
So that's why that book
is historical fiction.
The facts about the league are true
but my main character is made up.
I've also written a book about
the first subway in New York City.
And before I tell you about that
book, I just have a question.
Has anyone ever seen
litter in the streets?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Has anyone
ever been stuck in traffic?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Well,
believe it or not,
the litter in the streets especially
in New York City was even worse
150 years ago than it is today.
In fact, it's so bad, I don't even
know if I should show you a picture.
Your teachers might get upset.
Eew, it's so gross.
You're sure you want to see it?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, this
is what the litter looked
like 150 years ago.
>> Eew.
>> Shana Corey: So this was before
street cleaning, before recycling,
before alternate side parking
and the streets were a mess!
So they were gross and in fact, can
anyone tell me how did people get
around 150 years ago
before there were cars?
How did they get around?
>> Walk.
>> Horses pulling the carts.
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: Horses
pulled people in carts.
So if there were a lot
of horses on the street,
what else do you think was on
the street that horses produced?
>> Oh.
>> Shana Corey: What do you think?
>> Poop.
>> Shana Corey: Yes, horse poop.
So the streets were
really, really gross.
There's another picture.
Also, they hadn't invented
things like stoplights.
That's a picture of Broadway
in New York City in the 1850s.
They hadn't invented
stop signs or stop lines,
stoplights or even lanes.
Look, there are no lanes in that
picture because traffic was new.
So this man named Alfred
Ely Beach had an idea.
He was going to invent a subway.
So have any of you ever
read, rode the Metro here?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Shana Corey: So Beach wanted
to invent -- you just did.
He wanted to invent a
different kind of subway.
He wanted to invent a subway
that ran on pneumatic power.
Does anyone know what
pneumatic power is?
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, I need -- do
you know what pneumatic power is?
>> Pneumatic power is that
the subway stays on forever.
>> Shana Corey: That
the subway what?
>> Stays on forever.
>> Shana Corey: Stays old forever?
>> On.
>> Shana Corey: Stays on forever.
That's a really good thought.
Would you be my volunteer?
I need someone to come volunteer
and demonstrate pneumatic power.
Come, come up here.
So are you really good at Science?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, we have
a scientist here who's going
to demonstrate pneumatic
power for us.
Can you take this and blow it?
Whoa! So I have a question for you.
I didn't see you take
your hand and move that.
What force did you use to move that?
>> Wind.
>> Shana Corey: Wind.
Air and that's what
pneumatic power is.
It's air power.
So Beach used air power.
You want to hold on to that?
Here, let me hold onto it.
You can have it at the end.
Thank you so much.
Can we give her a round of applause?
So Beach used air, people, to
move his subway back and forth.
Now the book I'm going to read
today is a book about this person.
Who is that?
>> John F. Kennedy.
>> Shana Corey: John F. Kennedy --
who would be a hundred at the end
of -- at the end of this month.
And he inspires me because he's a
real person and he had a decision
to make if he was going
to be brave and stand
up for something he believed in.
So should we read the
story and see what he did?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yes, okay.
I'm going to -- let's see
if I can put this here
so I can turn the pages in my
book and read a little up closer.
Yes, okay.
A Time To Act , so do
you guys, what's it called
when a book is about a person?
Do you know the name?
What kind of book is about a person?
Yes.
>> What's the --
>> Shana Corey: No?
So you --
>> Biology?
>> Shana Corey: Close.
Biography -- you guys
are such smart kids.
Biography -- so this is a
biography of John F. Kennedy.
So it's also nonfiction
and I'm going
to read it here and turn the pages.
>> Oh.
>> Shana Corey: John F. Kennedy
loved to read about history.
But history isn't just in books.
It's happening all
around us and the people
who make history aren't just famous
leaders or characters in stories,
they're real people just like you.
Sometimes, they are you.
John or Jack as he was
called, was the second
of nine children in
a big, rich family.
If you saw the Kennedys, you
might think they had everything.
But take a closer look.
Jack wasn't the favorite.
That was his big brother, Joe.
Their father wanted Joe to
grow up to be the president.
No one was sure what Jack would be.
Jack didn't always
do well in school.
"He is casual and disorderly and
can seldom locate his possessions,"
said one of his teachers.
And he was often sick.
But Jack was funny
and people liked him.
When Jack was too sick to
play outdoors, he read.
Jack's mother taught her
children the importance
of giving back to one's country.
Jack took that belief seriously.
When the United States entered
World War II, he joined the fight.
On August 2, 1943 an enemy ship
ripped into the boat he commanded.
Jack led their survivors to safety,
towing one of the injured for more
than three miles by the
man's lifeboat strap.
He carried the lifeboat strap
in his teeth while he swam.
>> Wait, what about that other page?
>> Shana Corey: That other page?
I'm reading.
I'm not reading the whole
thing because I want
to make sure we have time
for questions and for me
to show you how it became a book.
Jack's brother, Joe,
also served his country.
But Joe wasn't as lucky as Jack.
A year after Jack's rescue,
Joe was killed flying
over the English Channel.
The family was heartbroken.
Now, it was up to Jack to carry
out his father's dreams for Joe.
In 1946, Jack ran for Congress.
His whole family helped.
After six years as a congressman,
Jack was elected to the Senate.
Americans loved the handsome young
senator and his new wife, Jackie.
They were celebrities.
Soon after they were married,
Jack had back surgery.
While he recovered, he wrote another
book with the help of his staff.
Profiles in Courage told
about people who had the courage
to take a stand for things
they believed in even
when they weren't popular.
Have you guys ever done
something really brave?
>> I have.
>> Shana Corey: What?
Have any of you guys
ever done something
that you feel like is really brave?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: What have
you done that's really brave?
What -- because Jack was interested.
He wrote a whole book about
people who did brave things.
>> I ran into the pool and I
didn't even know how deep it was.
>> Shana Corey: Going into a pool,
that's really brave especially
if you're not sure about it.
What else have you done
that's really brave?
>> I have a nine-feet
pool and I jumped
into the deep feet even
though that I was scared.
>> Shana Corey: Oh, wow!
Jumping into a pool is
a really brave thing.
You guys are a bunch of brave kids.
So hold on -- we'll do
more in a little bit.
On January 2, 1960, Jack announced
he was running for president.
Hold on, I'm juggling
a lot of things.
For president of the United States
-- years of practice had turned him
into a powerful speaker but not
everyone thought he would win.
Do you think it would be
hard to run for office
if people were saying
you couldn't win?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah, he was 42
years old, younger than every,
any president who had
ever been elected before.
President Dwight D.
Eisenhower called him
that young whippersnapper.
Eleanor Roosevelt thought Jack's
father was spending too much money
to help him get elected.
"My dear boy," she telegrammed,
"I only say these things
for your own good."
And Jack was Catholic.
Many people believe the country
wouldn't elect a Catholic.
"I believe in an America
where religious intolerance
will someday end," said Jack.
>> That's really for you.
>> Wait.
>> Shana Corey: That is
-- that is Ruby pictures.
Look, the pictures
right before, behind it.
America was also in
the midst of a long,
hard struggle over civil rights.
Civil rights are the rights of
all people to be treated fairly
without being discriminated against.
In many places, black people
were not treated fairly
and the south especially, a system
called segregation kept black people
apart from white people.
Even though the Supreme Court -- and
did you guys pass the Supreme Court
on its way here, on the
way here, it's just right
down the street -- had
declared it illegal.
Black people were not allowed to go
to the same schools as white people.
They were not allowed to drink from
the same water fountains or eat
in the same restaurants or
stay in the same hotels.
Black people couldn't always get
the same jobs as white people
and sometimes, they
were kept from voting.
Many Americans, both civil rights
leaders like Martin Luther King Jr.
and others who weren't famous,
even students, even kids just
like you guys, were trying to change
that through peaceful protests.
Have any of you ever
been to a protest?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah,
that's really exciting.
So you guys, if you've
been to protests,
you're already part of history.
You're part of history just
like the people in this book.
>> I've been to a protest.
>> Shana Corey: You've
been to a protest?
So you're working to change
history and to make history.
That's how you make
history by being part of it.
And you guys are already doing that.
>> I went to the --
>> Women's March?
>> The Women's March.
>> Shana Corey: The Women's March?
>> I told Donald Trump that we --
that we should be where we want.
>> Shana Corey: Wait, so you
went to the Women's March.
>> So we can show Donald
Trump that we're --
>> That love is --
>> That love is stronger.
>> And that's where she made a sign.
>> That says --
>> Shana Corey: You made a sign?
>> That says love is stronger.
>> Shana Corey: That's fabulous!
So you're part of history.
You guys are changing history.
You're making your voices heard
and telling people how you
want our country to be.
Good job. Good job, all of you.
So here are some more kids
that were part of protests.
Just a month after Jack announced
he was running for president,
four college students in Greensboro,
North Carolina began a sit-in.
So does anyone know
what a sit-in is?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: It's a protest when
you're sitting to make a statement.
So I'll read about it.
They sat quietly and peacefully
at a whites-only lunch counter
and waited to be served.
They were refused.
Every day, more and more
students joined them.
By the end of the week, the sit-ins
had spread across the country.
I'll turn the page.
That October, Martin Luther King
was arrested and sent to prison
after participating in a sit-in.
His wife, Coretta Scott-King,
feared he would be killed.
Jack's campaign worked
secretly with Georgia's governor
to get Dr. King released.
Some of Jack's advisers worried
that would cost him the votes
of white people who didn't
support civil rights.
So do you think that stopped him
or do you think he still wanted
to help Martin Luther King?
>> He wanted to help
Martin Luther King.
>> Shana Corey: But Jack
telephoned Mrs. King.
"If there is anything I
can do to help," he said,
"please feel free to call on me."
On November 8, 1960, Jack was
elected the 35th president
of the United States.
Hold on to your -- can you hold
on to your thought for a minute
and we'll do questions at the end?
>> Okay.
>> Shana Corey: In some things, the
new president acted quick -- whoop!
Thank you.
In some things, the new president
acted quickly and used bold words.
He established the Peace Corps and
challenged young Americans to go
out into the world and
work shoulder-to-shoulder
with people in other countries.
The United States and the Soviet
Union were rivals competing
to be the strongest.
The Soviet Union had already
sent a man into space.
Have you guys heard
about the space race?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yes, Jack declared
that the United States would be the
first to land the man on the moon.
But on other things, in
important civil rights issues,
Jack was slow to act.
He once declared that the
president must be willing
to get in the thick of fight.
But now, he seemed unwilling
to fight some battles.
"I would like to be patient,"
the famous baseball player
Jackie Robinson wrote to Jack,
"but patience has cost us years in
our struggle for human dignity."
So he's moving really fast in
some things but in other things,
he's moving a little
slower like on civil rights.
But others were taking action.
In that May, despite the danger,
hundreds of black children
and teenagers once again
stood up and acted.
They left their classrooms
in Birmingham, Alabama
and singing songs of freedom,
marched peacefully to
protest segregation.
They were hauled off to jail.
But the next day, even more young
people arrived to take their places.
So in the Civil Rights Movement,
a lot of young people were
right at the forefront.
They were the ones
making change and saying,
"We have to do something different.
We have to make our voices heard."
Americans including Jack, saw the
young people's courage on the news
and were sickened by the violence.
On June 11th, two black
students applied to enroll
at the University of Alabama.
Alabama's white governor
pledged to block them.
Again and again, young people
had shown their courage.
Do you think Jack's
going to act now?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Jack had to act.
And finally, following
in the footsteps of those
who would set the course by sitting
in and sending letters, marching
and riding buses, he did.
Jack ordered the National Guard
to escort the students safely
into school and that night,
in living rooms, in kitchens,
in diners across America, millions
of people of all colors, children
and parents and grandparents,
rich people and poor people,
people from the North and
people from the South,
people of different religions,
people who had looked the other way
and people who had fought for
change, turned on their televisions
and radios and heard
the president speak.
Okay, this is some of
what the president said.
So he made this very important
speech on civil rights.
He said, "One hundred
years of delay has passed
since President Lincoln freed
the slaves yet their heirs,
their grandsons are not fully free.
This nation will not be fully free
until all its citizens are free.
Now the time has come for this
nation to fulfill its promise.
It is a time to act."
So that's where that
title comes from.
So after that speech,
Martin Luther King
and the baseball player Jackie
Robinson, sent Jack telegrams
and letters and said, "Good."
They basically said, "Good job."
Jackie Robinson said, "The
presidential statement
on the color question is one of
the finest declarations ever issued
in the cause of human rights."
Because presidents hadn't
really said that before.
Sometimes, they had said, "Oh, you
know, we need to end segregation."
But they had never really said that
it's totally and completely wrong.
They had made it sound
like it was about politics.
And Jack Kennedy was the first one
that said, "No, it's just wrong."
The following week, Jack sent
a strong Civil Rights bill
to Congress.
So do you think he sent almost
right across the street to Congress
and the Senate Building
right across the street?
It's pretty cool that you
guys are right in the place
where all of this happened.
President Kennedy was
killed on November 22, 1963,
just a few minutes out
or just a few months
after he addressed the
nation on civil rights.
But his legacy, his words
and actions live on.
Today, the Soviet Union
no longer exists
but young Peace Corps volunteers
still go out into the world,
building roads and bridges,
libraries and schools.
On July 20, 1969, Kennedy's
space challenge was met.
Two American astronauts
walked on the moon.
And on July 2, 1964 with the
help of many courageous people,
people who didn't give
up, the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 was finally passed
making it illegal to discriminate
in jobs based on the color
of one's skin and providing
for the integration of
schools and public places.
Hold on one second and then we'll
do questions in a little bit.
In the 50 years since
the bill was passed,
there has been much
progress on civil rights.
But there have been
step backwards too.
History isn't a straight line.
And it's not words written
in books and permanent ink.
It's changing.
We're changing it every day.
You guys, when you go to protests
and things, you're changing history.
"From here on out, you
are the decision makers,"
Jack once told young people.
"You are the writers of history.
And so now, it's your turn to choose
your course, to speak up, to act,
to move the world forward,
to make history."
So kids your age can
and have made history.
You guys are part of history.
So I was going to show you guys,
do you want to see how
this story became a book
and then we'll have
time for questions?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: So I'll show
you, when I first wrote this,
the first thing I do is
I look for inspiration.
And you guys were talking
about where you get your ideas
and someone said, "Pictures."
I get a lot of ideas
from photographs.
These are some of the real pictures
of John F. Kennedy's family.
I know you guys saw some
Kennedy memorabilia upstairs.
Did you see pictures?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yes.
So he's the second oldest.
Here's another picture
of his family later.
He's right in the middle
in the back.
But even more, as much as I was
inspired by John F. Kennedy,
I was even more inspired by
the people he was inspired by,
the people that were really creating
the change, those brave kids
that were showing their
courage by protesting.
Who knows, who is that?
Does anyone who -- who?
>> Ruby Bridges.
>> Shana Corey: Everyone knows.
Who is that?
>> Ruby Bridges?
>> Shana Corey: You guys, I
can't get over these kids.
They are so smart.
Yes, that's Ruby Bridges.
So she was the first
black student to integrate
in elementary school, right?
What were you going to say?
>> Why did she have to go
to the white kid's school?
>> Shana Corey: You know,
that's a really good question.
She wanted to.
She wasn't -- she hadn't been
allowed to but usually the schools
that the white kids went
to had better resources.
They had more money so they --
she wanted to have the same things
that her parents wanted her to
have because she deserved just
as good an education as
everyone else, right?
>> Why would the [inaudible]?
>> Shana Corey: That's
a really good question.
You know, have you heard -- noticed
sometimes when some people think
that some people are worried
that they're going to --
if they share with people
that they won't have as much.
I think it had to do with that.
Some people felt like they
wanted to keep all the good stuff
so they would keep the other
people out and they felt
like they wanted all the good stuff.
And yeah, it wasn't a fair system.
The Supreme Court said
it was unfair, right?
And so now we could be together.
I was also inspired.
These are some of the real kids.
Remember in the book, the march
when the kids left their classrooms
in Birmingham and marched?
That's called the Children's
Crusade.
Here are some of the
real kids who marched.
Just like you guys when some of
you said you had marched recently.
And I was inspired by those kids.
So when I started reading
about Kennedy --
>> I marched.
>> Shana Corey: When you
marched, I wanted to write
about the kids that inspired him.
So then I started writing.
I also found lots of old documents.
This is a letter John F. Kennedy
wrote when he was a little boy.
Here are some telegrams he got.
There's a telegram from Eleanor
Roosevelt that says, "My dear boy,"
and then I started
writing my rough draft.
You know, my rough
drafts are kind of messy.
I don't know if I should
show it to you.
They're --
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: Okay, this is
what my rough drafts look like.
This is a rough draft
for my baseball book.
>> Wow.
>> Shana Corey: So if you were in
the library and you could check
out any book you wanted,
how many of you would get
that if you saw it on the shelf?
What --
>> I won't.
>> Shana Corey: Not many, right?
What's it missing?
What does it need before
it can be a book?
What's it missing?
>> It's missing pictures and
it's missing a front page.
>> Shana Corey: It's missing
pictures, a title page.
One more -- what else is it missing?
>> It's also missing the title.
If it had a title, then they
would actually be a book.
>> Shana Corey: If it had a title,
it actually would be a book.
Okay, one more.
What else is it missing?
What does it need before
it can be a book?
>> It could be a book with
[inaudible] they wanted
and everything that it has to
be, I'll have pictures on it.
>> Shana Corey: You're right.
Not all books have pictures.
You're absolutely right.
And it is pretty messy, right?
>> No.
>> Shana Corey: No?
Should we get one more?
What were you going to say?
>> It's missing a period.
>> Shana Corey: Is it?
It probably is.
And I can't even tell.
It's missing -- I think it's
missing correct spelling.
It's missing pages.
It's pretty messy.
So what I do after my
first draft is I revise.
I -- who can tell me,
what does revise mean?
What does revise mean?
>> You do it again.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah, I do it again.
So I keep working on it to
make it better and better.
And when it's as good as
I can possibly make it,
I type it all neatly.
Here's a typed up version of a
book I did about the Girl Scouts.
And I sent it to my editor.
Now, how many people think when
I send my typed up, very neat,
spellchecked version to my
editor, she says, "It's brilliant.
It's perfect.
We're going to publish
tomorrow just like this."
Is that what you guys think?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah?
You see, I think that every
single time and it never happened.
Instead, she sends it
back to me full of ideas
for how I can revise it more.
You want to see what she sent
me back when I sent her this?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: So this
is about Daisy Low,
the founder of Girl Scouts.
Here is what she said back to me.
>> Oh [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: If you look,
all of those are comments
about ways I can make
the story better.
I think in this one, the only thing
she said I could keep was the main
character's name.
And that's only because
it's nonfiction.
It really was her name.
Everything else she wants me to
change and try to make it better
because if we're going to ask you
guys to take your time to read it,
we really need to work as hard
as we can to make it good.
And then the last thing we do is
we send it to the illustrator.
This illustrator's name is R.
Gregory Christie for this book.
And the illustrator
does some sketches.
So that's what his sketches look
like before he does these beautiful
paintings that you see behind me.
And for covers -- covers
can take a really long time,
just like authors revise and
revise to get their stories right.
Illustrators revise and revise
[inaudible] art for that.
Here are some of what Greg Christie
when he was working on the cover.
This is what the final
cover looks like.
Put it here so you guys can see.
But you can see these
are some things
when he was experimenting
with different ideas.
Getting different ideas down.
These are just he was thinking
maybe we should have Kennedy walking
to the podium?
>> I would [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: What?
>> It doesn't [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: Sorry, a couple
didn't come through but so look,
all these different ideas.
But when we were talking
about these, we had a thought.
It's great to see Kennedy in these
but what was Kennedy's
big inspiration?
The book's about who
inspired Kennedy?
Yeah, who inspired Kennedy?
>> What does inspire mean?
>> Shana Corey: Inspire means
who made him give his speech?
Who --
>> Yes, Martin Luther King.
>> Shana Corey: Martin Luther
King and also who else?
>> The kids when they were marching.
>> Shana Corey: And also the kids.
But you're right, Martin
Luther King wrote to him
and said, "You need to do more."
And the kids marching and he saw
pictures of those kids marching
and being met by violence
and he thought
if they can do it, we
have to do something.
So R. Gregory Christie
decided, "You know what?
The kids need to be on the
front cover too because they're
as important as Kennedy
in this story at least."
So the final cover -- here, let's
see if I have the final cover
up there -- is it he'd brought
the real kids and he worked them
into the illustration
because that's --
so inspiration means the thing
that makes you do something.
So that was Kennedy's inspiration.
And that's everything I was going
to tell you guys about today.
Do you guys have questions for me?
Yes, questions.
>> Why did, if they
were making a sign,
why did they color the sign blue?
>> Shana Corey: Oh, good question.
I bet the real sign had words on it.
But I would guess, you know,
artists can all -- they always --
they can make their decisions on
what they think looks the best.
I think that it's probably,
if you put words on it,
it might distract from the title.
That would be my guess as to why
there aren't words on that sign.
Good question.
Yes.
>> So I kind of have
an answer to Kai.
So maybe since it's
-- so maybe that's --
so maybe the back of the sign was
actually supposed to be blue paper.
>> Shana Corey: Oh, that's a good --
because we could be looking
at the back of the sign there.
That's a good thought.
>> Why are they [inaudible]?
>> Shana Corey: Okay,
we'll come back.
Yes.
>> Why did they -- why did
they -- did he have a funeral?
>> Shana Corey: Kennedy?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: He did.
When he died which was
later, it was in November
of the same year that
he gave the speech.
He had a big, big funeral.
Any other question?
Yes.
>> What inspired you
to write the book?
>> Shana Corey: To write this book?
I was interested in
writing about Kennedy
because I knew it was
his hundredth birthday.
But what I was really interested is
I knew he was president during the
Civil Rights Movement.
And I didn't know what
his involvement was.
I had always read about those
two parts of history separately.
I had read about Kennedy and
then I'd read about things
like the sit-in and Ruby Bridges.
And I wondered what
was he actually doing?
He was the president.
He had to be involved in it.
And so I started trying to research
and find out what he was doing.
Good question.
Yes.
>> What did you really like
about in the book about Kennedy?
>> Shana Corey: What do I like
in the book about Kennedy?
I can tell you my favorite piece
of art is -- it's not here.
It's a piece of art that's all
the kids watching television.
I find that really powerful
because you see kids all over,
different kids, you know, some kids
from the South, some from the North
and I thought it must be
powerful to have a president stand
up for something that
you know is right.
Actually, did any of you guys
-- you probably didn't --
there's the book that Kennedy
wrote called "Profiles in Courage"
about brave people,
they're awards --
Profile in Courage Awards and they
just gave them out this past week.
And guess who got the
Profile in Courage Award?
>> John F. Kennedy.
>> Shana Corey: John
F. -- good, good idea.
This year, it went to
President Barack Obama.
So that was cool.
>> He was my favorite
president [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: He was
your favorite president?
Well, you can hear his speech.
He just -- just this past week, he
talks about Kennedy which was neat.
>> He's very famous.
>> Shana Corey: He is very famous.
Yes?
>> How come when Martin Luther King
got shot, how come segregation end?
>> Shana Corey: You know, it didn't
end right away like officially,
it ended with the Civil Rights Act.
And even before the Civil Rights
Act, there was a Supreme Court case
that said there shouldn't
be segregation.
But history, it can
take a long time.
Change happens slowly.
I think we want it to
happen faster, right?
I know I do but change happens --
>> Like what the [inaudible].
>> I thought that everybody
[inaudible] and he still got shot
that they would just
end it right away.
>> Shana Corey: I know,
it would be nice
if it had just ended right away.
I think it's also that you have
to keep working for things, right?
Because sometimes, it's
like we could relax
and think something's all done.
That's why in the book, I talk
about how like we have gone forward
but then we slide backwards too.
So that's why we have to
keep marching and protesting
in for things we believe in.
Yes.
>> Why did, why did the guy
shoot him in the first place?
>> Because he's mad at him.
>> Shana Corey: Kennedy
or Martin Luther King?
>> Why was he mad at him?
>> Martin Luther King.
>> He didn't like him.
>> Shana Corey: Martin
Luther -- because --
>> He met Kennedy.
>> Shana Corey: He met Kennedy?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Corey: You
know, there are --
>> He didn't like any
neighbor that had [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: I think he just --
you know, I honestly don't know.
I think he didn't agree
with him but [inaudible].
>> He didn't like the speech.
>> Shana Corey: He did
not like the speech.
It was a little bit later.
But I think a lot of times, it's
dangerous being a president.
That's why presidents have
the Secret Service, right.
Have you guys ever
seen Secret Service?
>> Yeah.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah, so now they
actually do a lot more safety things
than they used to do like they
don't have open cars and stuff
so that their presidents
can be a little safer.
But yeah, it's much better
to -- if you have concerns,
to peacefully protest,
right, versus violence?
Yes.
>> I know that so when
I saw that picture,
I thought so I knew it was going to
be like that because on the book,
in the red writing, it said -- it
says "John F. Kennedy's Big Speech."
>> Shana Corey: It does say that.
So we had a lot of -- I'll tell you
a few little behind-the-scene things
about that picture.
When we first saw the
painting, it was all in color.
And that's something the artist
revised because we started thinking
about it and what do you guys know
about televisions from
a long time ago?
What do you know about
-- you kids are so smart.
>> It was black and white.
It was black and white.
>> Shana Corey: Yeah, a lot of TVs,
most TVs were still black and white.
So he had to go back and change
the art because we realized, wait,
that probably wouldn't
have been in color.
And we also did a lot to the title,
"A Time To Act" comes
from the speech he gave.
Those were some of the words.
And then we had to -- we debated
whether it should be John F.
Kennedy's Big Speech or JFK's
Big Speech because a lot
of people called him JFK.
What would you guys have done?
>> [Inaudible] the F there for?
>> Shana Corey: Fitzgerald,
that was his -- yes.
>> Back then, TV was
not really invented.
>> Shana Corey: But it was invented.
>> And I saw a real live
TV way, way back then
and also something what I
did brave was go under water
when I didn't even, when I was,
when I didn't even want to do it.
>> Shana Corey: That
is really brave.
A lot of people did
brave water things.
Yeah, so TV was just invented.
That's why the book says a lot of
people listened to it on the radio
because not everyone had a TV
and the government
didn't have the internet.
No one was live streaming
the speech.
But you know what, you guys, you
can actually watch the speech.
You can go online and
your teacher can find --
you can watch a video
of this actual speech.
It's on my website
or the JFK Library.
Yes.
>> So not all the people who
helped our country is black.
Not all of them.
>> Shana Corey: No, you're right.
They were certainly,
there were white people
and other people that
helped too, right?
Allies? Yes.
>> I know the last name of the
person who killed John F. Kennedy.
>> Who?
>> Shana Corey: What?
>> His last name is Oswald.
>> Shana Corey: You're right.
Yes.
>> Oswald?
>> What month was his funeral?
>> Shana Corey: You
know, I would assume --
he died in November
-- November 22nd.
I actually don't offhand
know the date of his funeral
but I bet it was still November.
>> I know the [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: You
know the sit-in book?
Is it the one, the four
friends sitting there?
I love that book.
That's a wonderful book.
There are wonderful books
about the -- about the sit-in.
Yeah, there's a wonderful book about
-- there are several wonderful books
about Martin Luther King.
There's great books
about Ruby Bridges.
Ruby Bridges actually wrote a kid's
book that you can find to read
when -- it's just interesting.
>> Are you going to [inaudible]?
>> Shana Corey: I don't
know if you guys are going
to get read books here after.
Are they reading books?
If not, I'm sure you can come
back and I bet you have a lot
of these books in your school.
>> Didn't the person who got,
who killed John F. Kennedy,
didn't he get hanged?
>> Shana Corey: No, he didn't.
But he was -- that's a good thought.
He was actually, he was shot.
He was someone --
>> Yeah, someone shot
him [inaudible].
>> I know the person
who [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: You guys, I
think know more about Kennedy.
>> I know who killed Oswald.
>> Shana Corey: Who killed Oswald?
>> Jack Ruby, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Jack Ruby.
>> That's right.
>> Shana Corey: Jack Ruby.
And there are books about that too.
That's the thing.
One of the neat things about writing
is you can write different things.
So this book is really about
Kennedy and civil rights.
But there are books, I know
lots of great books too,
that talk about his assassination.
There are some early
readers that are really good
about him too and other
picture books.
>> Then Oswald also got arrested
for killing John F. Kennedy.
>> Shana Corey: Yes.
Yes.
>> The person who killed John F. --
the person who killed John F.
Kennedy and then the person
who shot the person who shot John
F. Kennedy, who shot that person?
>> Shana Corey: Yes, it was
a really intense time, right,
of American history
because it was all --
>> It happened all in one day?
>> Shana Corey: No, I don't believe
it happened all in the same day.
No. Yes.
>> When was this book made?
>> Shana Corey: So this
book -- good question --
it just came out last month.
It was just published but
I really wrote it last year
because it takes a long time for --
the illustrator gets to do their
work after it's already written.
So I wrote it and then it
went to the illustrator.
Yes.
>> When -- when did
the segregation end?
>> Shana Corey: Good question, so
I believe with the Civil Right --
what were you going to say?
>> I know when slavery ended.
>> Shana Corey: When
did slavery end?
>> Nineteen -- 1869.
>> Shana Corey: Good.
>> I know when the first dependence
says we celebrate on the fourth
of July because that's in our
first dependence was wrote in.
>> Shana Corey: You're right.
You guys know such good --
>> And George Washington
was in the fight.
>> Shana Corey: And
George Washington was
in the revolutionary war and
then was the first president?
>> The first president [inaudible].
>> Shana Corey: So I think
segregation, it was --
it took longer to actually end
and when it became illegal.
>> So we -- so we kind of know this
other person named Paul Revere.
>> Shana Corey: I kind of know about
a person named Paul Revere too.
>> Oh, what is that?
>> Do this.
>> Shana Corey: It's
part of American history.
And Paul Revere has to do with
the American Revolution too.
I think Paul Revere
is very interesting.
Yes.
>> Are you writing another book?
What would it be about?
>> Shana Corey: Good question.
So right now, I'm actually writing
a book about Michelle Obama.
Yes.
>> Any [inaudible]?
>> Shana Corey: I think this
is the very last question.
>> Was the person who
killed JFK arrested?
>> Shana Corey: Yes,
he was arrested.
You guys have been
a wonderful audience
with fabulous questions
and fabulous answers.
Can you give yourselves
a round of applause?
[ Applause ]
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, guys, for being --
>> For now.
>> Shana Corey: What, sweetie?
>> There's no --
>> Oh yes, [inaudible] it's yes.
>> Shana Corey: Right,
if your teacher says
to put it away then you
have to put it away.
Thank you for being my volunteer.
>> Oh no.
>> Shana Corey: You're
going home from here?
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.